with me now is yael a pet leader of the
israeli opposition party yesh antique
mr. Lapid you strongly opposed the
labeling of goods from the occupied
territories why's that well because this
is the word trying to tell us how to run
our own business right now i'll give you
an example one of the products they
wanna label is the is coming from the
Golan Heights now the Golan Heights
there's not a single Palestinian living
there and even if we want to give back
the Golan Heights are we going to give
it back to because on the border of the
Golan Heights Hizbollah a terror
organization jabatan östra and Al
qaeda-affiliated terror organization
Isis terror organization and the little
that was left from the Assad regime that
has killed quarter of a million people
in the recent three in the last three
years so these are the people you want
us to give the Golan Heights back to so
this labeling is just a continuation of
the boycott Israel movement that is
anti-semite and wrong or the EU argues
the label gives consumers the
information they need what's so wrong
about that many Europeans are not happy
with the way Israel treats the
settlements and the occupied territories
you know this is just not true the EU is
hiding behind legal issues claiming or
trying to portray a picture in which you
say no it's only illegal [ __ ] is not
it's a political issue it's them giving
up to the worst elements of jihad the
least they can do is tell the truth
about what is it that they're really
trying to do what is their real trying
to do is to force Israel to do things in
so it doesn't want to do do you think
there is a growing anti-israel elak
sentiment in Europe and especially in
Germany Germany is full of goodwill and
we have we are thankful for that but in
the EU in general it is not anti-israeli
this is anti-semitism at its worst this
is people who are right now you know and
now
re going hour and a half ago two
Israelis were shot in heaven not because
something they did not because of the
occupation just because they're Jewish I
am for the two-state solution I am part
I'm not part of the coalition and part
of the opposition and yet I'm telling
you that labeling is just the wrong way
to go about this you are leader of the
opposition party yesh at Eton want to be
Prime Minister one day what would you do
different in terms of foreign policy
then now acting Prime Minister Benjamin
Netanyahu I made it into a rule never to
criticize Israel Prime Minister on
foreign soil I'm sure you'll understand
this it is known to every Israeli that I
think what we need to do is separate
from the Palestinians it's time it's not
peace that i'm seeking its separation
it's time for us to put a higher fence
between them and us to make sure that
the security arrangements i like that
that the Israel Defense army can operate
on the future Palestinian state in order
to preserve Israel's citizens security
but we need to separate from the
Palestinians Israel has no interest it's
not in our best interest to try and
absorb 3.5 million Palestinians because
this is a threat to us as a Jewish state
Yael a bit thank you for being with us
thank you so much